one alternative to mesh that I like to
offer patients is the use of their own
tissue something called an autologous
sling the autologous sling uses a small
bikini incision to harvest fashio which
lines all of our muscles to be used as
the sling this sling is then placed to
support the urethra in a very similar
fashion to the way mesh is used and that
helps to prevent urinary leakage we
often recommend robotic bypass surgery
for our patients we have diabetes and
other severe ailments of severe obesity
we have an animated video available that
we'd like to show you now it's meant to
educate the patients and the families if
you suffer from severe obesity and have
been unable to lose weight we may
recommend robotic gastric bypass surgery
what they explained was that they were
going to put a graft leading up to my
heart through my a order the part that
was damaged we cut out the a sending
aorta we cut out that up to the aortic
arch and sometimes we have to replace
the aortic arch and we replace it with a
polyester material called Dacron we so
the die upon to the order wall and we
suture these these materials together
with polypropylene which is a basically
efficiently
you